I'M C-CZAR.
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH.
I'M ABOUT TO BECOME
A TEENAGE DAD.
AND NOW SIX EXPERTS ARE GONNA
TEACH ME HOW TO BE THE ONE THING
THAT I NEVER HAD
IN MY OWN LIFE--A DAD.
FOR EVERY PAPA QUIZ I PASS,
I GET A DOPE-ASS TATTOO.
WELCOME TO THIS IS DAD ACADEMY.
EXCUSE ME.
OH, SNAP,
IT'S A LITTLE C-CZAR.
I KNOW. IT'S CRAZY.
CAN YOU BELIEVE IT?
I UNDERSTAND
THAT IF I WANT TO SEE
THE SHORTY MAKING MY BABY,
I MUST COME CORRECT,
WHICH I WILL,
TINY PROFESSOR.
- BYE-BYE.
- BYE. I LOVE YOU, C-CZAR.
SO TODAY I'M MEETING
MY FIRST DAD EXPERT,
AND I'M EXCITED
BUT ALSO ANNOYED.
- I'M THE WALLET.
- WHY DO I CALL YOU A WALLET?
YOU JUST A MAN.
- IN THE STRUCTURE
OF THIS SHOW,
THE DAD ACADEMY,
I REPRESENT THE WALLET.
I'M THE FINANCIAL PORTION
OF THE DAD PROGRAM,
AND IT'S MY JOB TO GET YOU
FINANCIALLY SOUND TODAY
SO THAT YOU CAN BECOME
THE GOOD DAD WE KNOW YOU CAN BE.
WE BROUGHT YOU TO A PLACE
THAT YOU CAN AFFORD
ON YOUR CURRENT BUDGET.
- OKAY.
- C-CZAR.
- WHAT?
- I THINK THE RESULTS
ARE GOING TO SHOCK
AND HORRIFY YOU.
- FOR REAL?
- YEAH.
- OKAY.
- C-CZAR, THIS IS IT.
- OH, SNAP,
THIS PLACE IS AWESOME.
- NO, THIS PLACE
IS NOT AWESOME.
- THAT'S MY OLD CRATE.
- WHAT?
- THIS IS MY HOUSE?
- THAT'S A KENNEL FOR A DOG.
- THIS IS WHAT I LIVED IN
FOR THE FIRST TWO YEARS
OF MY LIFE, C-CZAR.
I WAS CRATE-TRAINED.
- HE'S CALLING ME C-CZAR.
IS THAT...?
- I'M COMFORTABLE IN HERE.
- THAT AS IT MAY BE,
THE HOUSE IS ACTUALLY THIS WAY.
- OH, SNAP, SWEET HOUSE.
OH, SNAP,
MY VERY OWN BATHROOM.
LET THEM EAT CAKE.
OKAY, THIS IS WHERE BABY C-CZAR
WILL SLEEP.
OKAY.
OH, SNAP, THIS IS ALL MINE?
ALL RIGHT,
I'M GONNA SIGN MY LEASE.
- SO, C-CZAR, HOW ARE YOU
FINDING YOUR...?
WHO WROTE ON THE WALL?
- UH, THAT WAS HERE
WHEN I GOT HERE.